they say in brazil
god is brazilian and brazilians are just
as certain that their team will win the
next world cup
welcome to the land of football and
faith
however away from the glamour of the big
stadiums soccer provides more than just
a hope of a title
it offers kids a better life
the german soccer coach sasha bauer has
already made a name for himself in south
africa and mozambique
promoting what he calls social soccer
now he's been sent by the german aid
agency giz
and the german soccer federation to
train coaches in brazil
who work with young players from the
slums to get a better idea of the
conditions there
he visits the favelas on the outskirts
of rio de janeiro
you can only really understand how the
coaches work how good they are
and what problems
favelas about an hour and a half's drive
from the center of the city
with a new soft touch approach brazilian
police have brought the slums
surrounding the prosperous southern
suburbs under control
but here the drug gangs still rule
franklin ferreira has developed a social
soccer project
in vila allianza all on his own
you can see for yourself some of them
don't have any sports shoes
they play in their socks i can't stop
them playing or they would just hang out
on the streets
come along i'll introduce you
franklin ferreira coaches about 150 kids
a week
many of them neglected by their families
and the state
they're grateful for his commitment
ferrara's aim is to give the kids a
direction in life without destroying
their dream of one day becoming a soccer
star
like the legendary ronaldinho or the
current brazilian idol
neymar
i tell them you may not be a ronaldinho
or a neymar but you could become a good
sports teacher
lawyer or bricklayer my mission
is motivating them on the pitch and in
life
to be a soccer idol is one thing
in a continuous discussion about ideas
and values
such as mutual respect and helping each
other
before the session starts it's always
the same ritual
everyone helped pick up the trash from
the pitch
that's important to the coach there's a
general lack of environmental awareness
in brazil
especially in the favelas
his organization is called krakastavida
cracks in life while heavily armed gangs
circle the perimeter fence
ferrera wants to give the kids on the
soccer field a different perspective
there's a lot of violence here mostly
used to assert control over the
neighborhood
but i tell my kids that their lives
should be different
there's another way of doing things
and soccer is a key element
soccer is the greatest dream of
brazilians every kid wants a ball
brazilians are born with that desire
that's why we should use soccer to
socialize the kids
ferreira also comes from the slums but
he won a scholarship
and became a sports teacher and for 10
years he financed this
ngo with his own salary
eventually he managed to find a
multinational to sponsor his project
and buy all the kids team jerseys
the coach's aim is not to produce future
soccer stars
but to teach the kids fair play in
relating to one another
our methods are adapted to the
conditions here
this experience helps sasha bauer plan
his coach training program
franklin ferreira has registered to take
part
just a few kilometers away in guadalupe
apartment blocks have been constructed
for low-income families
this is currently a no-go area ruled by
drug gangs
but at the very center there's a soccer
oasis
means literally moving the ball forward
it's also the name of one of brazil's
largest
ngos dedicated to the concept of social
soccer
sasha bauer works for this institute
some eight hundred kids from the area
are coached in soccer
and their personal development is
encouraged
is a success story almost all the
participating kids finish school
and then do vocational training
the institute is financed by sponsorship
for instance a large sports goods
manufacturer donates the jerseys and
footwear
assisted by a social worker and one of
the institute's coaches
sasha bauer is developing a new method
treno social
social coaching the aim is to improve
the standard of soccer coaching for
young kids and teenagers
and to teach them social skills at the
same time
field organizations
many organizations start with soccer
coaching to harness the kids enthusiasm
and then they had a class but we're
trying to incorporate this into the
coaching session itself
so that the kids don't feel they're
getting an additional lesson
eleven-year-old gustavo comes here three
times a week after school
the kids have to show that they are
attending school regularly if they want
to take part
the coaches are taking stock
here too the emphasis is on the game
fairness is an essential part of that
our coach always says when there's a
quarrel here and the other guy hits you
how do you react when he's big
no violence on the pitch otherwise
you're suspended for a month
the kids can choose a second subject
gustavo picked music
but his dreams for the future are rather
different
i would like to join the navy that's a
good job
you can earn a lot of money then i can
support my family
and later be able to feed my own wife
and children
in the six favelas served by the
institute there is poor housing
no drainage no garbage collection
shocking conditions
many people here are sustained by their
faith
there are thirty churches serving six
thousand residents
most of them pentecostals that includes
gustavo's family
he has six brothers and sisters the
family lives in a single
small room
life is incredibly hard but the family
sticks together
the foundation of our family is god with
his help we get through life
lots of people think you can't achieve
anything if you come from a favela
but that's not true there are lots of
people here who have dreams
and fight for them
all the children go to the bola profe
institute after school
it's very important to the family with a
view to the children's future
neither of the parents have any
education they always wanted their
children
to have that opportunity and their dream
is gradually coming true
this is a victory for me the
certificates from classes the children
have taken at bola preferente
we collect everything we've been very
lucky
lots of people wouldn't think it's much
what just a course
but it means a lot to us
after six months of preparation the
first classes in social coaching start
in one of the buildings of the sports
college in rio
they will last a week and then be
offered in four more brazilian cities
giorgino makes a star appearance at the
opening he played for the national side
when brazil won the world cup in 1994
and was on the team when bayern munich
topped the bundesliga
when he retired from professional soccer
giorgino founded the bola proferente
institute
in the same favela where he grew up
be passionate about your work it's not
meaningless
you can change human lives
he's good at giving pep talks if he
hadn't become a soccer star
he would probably have become a pastor
he says like his brother
when jorginho was playing for germany he
established a bible study group for
soccer players
the devout pentecostal won fifa's fair
play award
on the field and in everyday life his
faith is his strength
when i look back what have i achieved
i've played great soccer on the national
team
seen great stadiums luxurious hotels
beautiful countries
but my life has to have more meaning
and then i can look back and say i've
really done something
not just for myself and my family but
for other people
for my neighbor and i've learned a lot
with jesus christ
they start with a game to give the
participants a chance to get to know
each other
from tall to short no speaking
they come from various backgrounds
former soccer professionals
teachers students a doctor who is an
amateur coach
what do they have in common they all
work in the city's flashpoints
where they are often left to their own
resources
a very important element in this course
is that we discuss what we've
experienced
we share our experiences understand
difficult situations and then look for
solutions
often another coach could be working
just two kilometers away and having the
same problem
but they never communicate with each
other and one of the coaches has found a
solution
and the other hasn't
the class is divided into groups to
discuss the role of the coach
franklin ferreira's group says the most
important thing is to give the kids
attention
and demonstrate
we're very often a substitute family for
the kids
he's developed new coaching methods for
three age groups
they focus on four social areas
environment health equality and
violence prevention that kind of
coaching requires lots of preparation
planning is taken very seriously in
germany
there if you go onto the field without a
formulated plan it can get complicated
is there anyone here who's done that
written out a coaching plan with a
variety of exercises
only one person sasha bauer
explains how a plan makes coaching more
systematic
in selecting suitable exercises
preparing them
and not forgetting any aspect in
practice
this means repeating exercises regularly
and dividing the players into small
groups
that way each kid gets a lot of contact
with the ball
which increases their chance of success
and encourages their self-confidence
then it's on to the pitch to learn a
training session that's tailored to six
to eight-year-olds
today we're going to talk about the
environment and one of the most
important things is garbage separation
and you can do that in a number of ways
but you always
start at the top
lessons in recycling for two competing
teams
the coaches do a good job of imitating
their young players
they're really getting into it
then comes a question-and-answer game
so is big industry the only cause of
environmental pollution
for this exercise the kids will have to
dribble quickly to the marker with the
right answer
red means no white means yes
these cones represent trees and we're
not allowed to touch them
you can use various tricks this for
instance
okay go
lucia nacimento is one of just two women
in the group
she started and coached her first girls
team when she was 16.
since then she's been involved in social
soccer
she says she'll be able to apply the
methods she learns here
it's fun and creative we have to keep
control of the ball and at the same time
concentrate
that way we coach the kids cognitive and
intellectual abilities
they will be able to imagine that the
trees really exist
and then we'll be able to start a little
discussion on the subject
actually it's simple but people are so
used to difficult things that they find
it hard to simplify
the course will continue next year but
everyone feels they've learned a lot
already
the course has given me a lot of ideas
when i introduce these methods in my
favela
it'll be a revolution the priest at
franklin ferreira's church says
everybody in his favela believes in god
there aren't any atheists
although protestant evangelists have
been working in the favelas in recent
years
and winning converts brazil still has
the largest
catholic population of any country in
the world
the human being is a creator we work for
god
to make a better world a better society
give us peace they sing in this favela
plagued by drug-related violence
the priest himself runs a project to
help kids distance themselves from the
drug scene
he encourages his parishioners to get
involved in social programs
and see sport as an important aspect
through sport we rescue a lot of kids
from the drug trade and addiction
also through faith
it provides
a short distance away in the northwest
district of jacqueline pagua
are lucia naciamento is preparing her
first session of social coaching for the
kids
the way she's been taught to do
in this session my aim is for them to
think about gender a bit
about the
it's very unusual in brazil but here
girls and boys
ranging from 12 to 20 something play
together in this group
sasha bauer has come to watch
they'll take the ball up to there turn
around in two groups just like we
learned
a memory game with homemade cards all on
the subject
of gender differences
the first group to discover all the
pairs wins
in the final round the meaning behind
the selected pictures is discussed
because he doesn't have a woman to do it
why do women get paid less for doing the
same work
i see it in the supermarket where i work
there are only female cashiers because
men would have to be paid more
women used to just be housewives now
they clean the house
work study and their husbands
do they help
when you have a wife and children one
day
before i come here i have to tidy up the
house my brother doesn't he says i'm
going to play soccer and he goes
i don't wash dishes here the man works
and brings home the money to buy
everything the family needs and the
woman looks after the household
that may be macho but that's the way it
is
these machos we tell them what we think
even if they don't agree
they get angry but sometimes they also
think about the other side of the story
so far so good sasha bauer offers to
supervise the coach over a longer period
and help her establish and develop the
new method in her day-to-day work
i have to say andalusia demonstrated a
very high standard today
she has the right teaching skills which
you can't expect every coach to have
many of them have a soccer background
and not as much teaching experience
so i was delighted to see how she put
the method into practice this
is brazil's soccer temple the maracana
is one of the world's most famous
stadiums
the world cup final will be played here
in july
the stadium is a magnet for the
country's young hopefuls
brazil is already the most successful
team ever
it has already won the world cup five
times
none of the kids from the favela can
afford a ticket
but they dream one day entering the
stadium wearing the brazil
jersey
they've already got it all worked out
play abroad in a good team then come
back
all that matters is to play and get what
you deserve
what is
especially hard for kids like us from
the
as the world focuses on brazil and the
world cup franklin ferrera hopes that
international awareness of social soccer
will increase
soccer is not just a sport in many
countries it's a religion
foreign investors are coming and these
kids could benefit
the world cup must leave our country a
social legacy
and i hope the projects benefit
the whole world has its eyes on brazil
naturally we want to raise the approval
and attention that projects get
so that the ngos receive more support at
various levels
and as far as the future world champions
are concerned
there's no room for anything but
confidence
for if god really is brazilian there's
only one possible outcome
you